안녕하세요 요즘에 부동산 경매 매물이
쏟아지고 있다라고 하는데 부동산
경매는 채무자가 이제 빛을 갚지
못해서 채권자가 채무자의 자산을
법원에 경매 신청을 해서 채권을
회수하는 법적 절차를 이야기를 합니다
그래서 부동산 경매가 생기는 이유는
대출 원금이나 이자를 갚지 못했거나
아니면 공과금을 밀렸나 소송을 통해서
진행하는 경우가 있는데 보통 이제
예를 들면 자녀간에 이렇게 공동
명의로 부동산을 소유했을 때 분쟁도
되게 많이 생기거든요 공 을 분할
청구 소송을 하는 경우가 있는데
그거를 통해서 부동산 경매로 나오는
경우도 많습니다 부동산 경매는
일반적으로 6개월에서 최대한 1년
정도 소요가 됩니다 부동산 경매를
진행 중일 때는 등기 사한 정부
증명서에 경매 개시 결정이라고 이렇게
나와 있어요 그게 나와 있는 경우에는
부동산 경매가 진행 중이구나 이렇게
생각하시면 될 거 같습니다 그리고
경매 취아 조건으로 거래하는 경우도
있어요 채권자 변제를 조건으로 경매
치야 조건으로 거래가 되는 경우도
있습니다 근데 최근에 고금리가 되게
장기간 이어지고 있고 내수 경기가
좋지 않기 때문에 경매 매물들이 좀
많이 늘어나고 있어요 최근에는 그
전세 보증금을 돌려주지 못해서 경매를
진행하는 건들이 정말 엄청 많이
늘어났습니다 특히 전세 사기가 많았던
지역들의 그런 주택들이 많이 나왔어요
화곡동이 그지 전세 사기가 많았던
그런 지역들 있잖아요 그런 지역들의
경매권 수가 굉장히 좀 많이
늘어났습니다 그리고 전세 비율이 되게
높은 부동산에 같은 경우에는 부동산
경기 침 체로 매매 가격이 줄어들어서
전세 가격이 매매 가격을 추월하는
역전세 현상들이 좀 많이 늘어났습니다
그래서 임차인 분들이 경매를 아무리
신청하더라도 내 보증금을 다 못 받는
경우가 되게 많아졌거든요 그리고 이제
갭 투자하던 분들이 감옥에 가거나
파산하는 경우가 되게 많아졌거든요
그래서 임차인들 피해들이 되게
많아졌습니다 근데 문제는 뭐냐면이
연글 투자하던 분들이 고소득 층뿐만
아니라이 저소득 층들도 그때 당시만
하더라도 대출 안 받으면 바보 집 안
사면 바보라는 얘기가 엄청 많이
흘렀거든요 진짜 무리해서 부동산을
투자하는 경우가 많았거든요 근데
그런게 금리가 높아지면서 이번에
부동산 경매로 많이 나오기
시작했습니다 그래서 연글 투자로
인해서 부동산 경매건수가 더 늘어났고
경매 물건 증가로 인해서 투자
수익률이 감소하면서 경매 낙찰가율이
내려갔습니다 그리고 연글 투자로 실패
사례가 많아지면서 경매 참여자들이
되게 신중해져 투자 심리가 되게
위축된 부분도 있습니다 저는 내년에도
부동산 경매 건수가 더 늘어날 것으로
예상이 됩니다 근데 이제 위기가
기회라는 얘기가 있듯이 부동산 경매로
취득하기에 정말 좋은 애라고 저는
생각을 합니다 2020년도
2021년도에는 경매장을 가도
사람들이 너무 많았어요 진짜
바글바글하고 그리고 낙찰가율도 더
높았습니다 오히려 감정가보다 더 높게
낙찰되는 경우가 많았어요 근데 요즘
같은 경우에는 인기가 있는 지역은
감전 가액보다 더 높게 낙찰이 되기도
하지만 그래도 그 전보다는 낙찰
받기에는 굉장히 좀 좋은시기 인 거
같습니다 올해 1월부터 11월까지
평균 낙찰 율은 약한 38에서 40%
정도 추정이 되고이는 전체 경매 건수
중에 약 한 60% 정도가 유찰이 된
겁니다 그래서 한 열건 중에 한 여섯
건 정도는 처음에 이제 유찰돼 그
정도로 지금 시기에 낙찰 받기에는 더
좋을 거 같고 내년에는 아마 더 좋을
겁니다 그래서 경매가 나오면 한 열건
중에 한 세내 건 정도만 낙찰이 되는
거예요 그리고 이제 다 유찰이 됩니다
그래서 되게 좋은 가격에 낙찰받을 수
있는 그런 기회들이 되게 는 거예요
그래서 호환기 때보다는 낙찰 받기에는
되게 좋은 시기라고 저는 생각을 하고
아만 경매 물건 중에 이제 인기가
있는 지역 같은 경우에는 입찰자가
열명이 넘는 경우도 많거든요 그렇게
좋은 부동산은 그래도 경쟁률이 되게
치열하다 이렇게 보시면 될 거
같습니다 그러니까 좋은 지역에 있는
부동산은 계속 높은 가격에 낙찰이
되거나 입찰자들이 많이 이차를 할
것으로 예상이 되고 인기가 없는
지역은 계속 유찰되고 아니면 낮은
가격에 낙찰되는 경우가 되게 많아질
것 같습니다 그 내년 뿐만 아니라
저는 양극화는 계속 더 커질거다
그니까 사람이 몰리는 데는 몰리고
빠지는 데는 빠지고 제가 어저께 기사
보니까 젊은 층들이 되게 없어졌잖아요
초등학교 중학생 뭐 고등학생들 인원이
다 빠지고 있잖아요 근데 강남구는 더
늘어났다고 합니다 지금 저출산이
학생들이 계속 없어져서 막 폐교하고
있고 그니까 서울 근교만 하더라도 다
그런 상황인데 강남구는 오히려 더
젊은 사람들이 늘어났어요 그래서
중학생 인구가 더 늘어났다고 합니다
그리 특히 강남구는 왜 그런 학생들이
많이 오냐며 거기에 있어야지 명문
학교들을 가거든요 그렇다 보니까
지방에서 올라오는 경우도 되게 많아요
그래서 거기 집값이 높을 수밖에
없어요 그런 것 때문에 그래서 앞으로
더 몰리는 데는 몰리고 그리고 앞전
데이터 보여 드렸던 것처럼 부자는
계속 많아지고 있습니다이 격차가 더
커지고 있어요 앞으로 뭐 경매도
똑같습니다 좋은 부동산은 계속
입찰자들이 많이 몰릴 거고 인기가
없는 건 더 빠질 거고 일본 도쿄도
비슷하잖아요 긴자 오모테 산도나 이런
좋은 지역은 가격이 계속 오르지만
거기서 조금만 벗어나도 가격이 지금
계속 빠지고 거래도 안 되거든요
우리나라도 이런 양극화가 더 심해질
것이다 저는 이렇게 예상합니다 부동산
경매와 일반 이제 매매에 좀 팁을
드리자면 일단은 내년에 부동산 경매로
취득하기에 좋은 시기라고 생각합니다
이건 팩트입니다 근데 앞서 설명드렸던
것처럼 부동산 경매가 나오기 전에
좋은 부동산들은 그냥 일반 매매로
팔리는 경우가 많거든요 그래서 일반
매매는 무조건 같이 봐야 될까 매물을
매물을 무조건 같이 보는데 경매도
유심히 좀 보셨으면 좋겠습니다 근데
대부분 다 경매를 안 보는 경우가
많거든요 내년에는 사기 좋은 시기이기
때문에 부동산 경매도 좀 같이
보셨으면 좋겠습니다 그리고 부동산
경매가 더 메리트인 경우도 있어요
예를 들어서 토지 거래 허가 구역
같은 경우에는 직접 거주를 해야지만
그 부동산을 취득을 할 수 있는데
경매를 통해서 낙찰받는 경우에는 직접
거주를 안 해도 됩니다 전세를 줘도
되거든요 그래서 부동산 경매 메리트가
있는 그런 지역의 부동산의 경우에는
부동산 경매를 통해서 좋은 조건에 어
아니면 더 높 높게 낙찰이 되기도
합니다네 그래서 부동산 경매를 통해서
매입할 때는 은행에서 대출 받는
경우도 있지만 실제로 현장 가면은
그분들 통해서 금리가 좀 높을 수
있겠지만 큰 돈 안 들이고 매입하는
경우도 있습니다 제가 봤을 때는 그냥
일반 매매보다는 진짜 뭐 90%
대출도 나와요 80% 90% 그
이상도 나오는 경우 있는데 아까
뭐라고 말씀드렸으니까 영꿀 투자의
위험성이 이자를 감당할 만한 능력이
안 된다라면 그렇게 높게 아지 대출을
받으면 안 돼요 그래서 내년에
어찌됐든 뭐 부동산 경매로 낙찰
받기엔 너무 좋은 시장입니다 일반
매매를 일단 우선으로 가져가고 부동산
경매도 좀 같이 보셨으면 좋겠고
대출은 내가 감당이 가능할 정도를
받아야 돼요 내년에 금리가 좀 내려갈
거라고 하긴 하지만 그래도 높은
수준에서 계속 좀 유지가 될 거 같긴
하거든요 대출은 내가 감당이 가능할
정도만 하지만이 부동산 경매로 취득할
때 권리 분석을 되게 철저하게 해야
됩니다 예를 들어서 대항력이 있는
임차인의 경우에는 나중에 보증금을
돌려주거나 아니면 명도에대 한 이슈가
생길 수가 있고 유치권이 그지 미압
관리 이라든지 추가 비용이 발생될
수가 있습니다 또한 이제 예상치
못했던 이런 명도 이슈가 발생될 수
있기 때문에 그런 경우에는 뭐
비용뿐만 아니라 기간도 많이 소요될
수 있기 때문에 철저한 분석이 좀
필요합니다 그리고 입찰가를 쓸 때
나만의 기준을 정해서 쓰는게 되게
중요한 거 같습니다 주식도 매수가를
정해서 매수를 걸어 놓는 것처럼
부동산 경매도 입찰가 기준을 정해서이
금액으로 낙찰이 안 되면 그냥 이제
내 것이 아니었구나 이렇게 편하게
생각하고 그냥 잊어버리는게 되게
중요합니다 근데 보통 이제 분위기에
휩쓸려 가지고 판단력이 되게 좀
흐려져 가지고 높게 입찰가를 쓰는
경우가 많거든요 그런 부분을 되게
조심하셔야 됩니다 뭐 처음에 만약에
부동산 경매를 하시려고 하시면
전문가의 도움을 받는게 되게
중요하다라고 생각하는데 약간 깨알
홍보를 하자면 저희가 부동산 경매도
하고 있습니다 만약에 여러분들이 빌딩
그 특히 서울시내 빌딩 사고 싶다라고
하면 저희가 뭐 주변에 매각 사례뿐만
아니라 인근에 나와 있는 빌딩들
가격도 다 알고 있거든요 그래서 어느
정도의 낙찰 받으면 좋겠다라고 조언도
드릴 수 있고 그리고 건축 설계라는
시공이라는 빌딩 관리라는 이런 조언도
가능하기 때문에 여러분들이 부동산
경매로 빌딩을 한번 낙찰받아
보겠다라는 분들은 편하게 연락 주셔도
좋을 것 같습니다 위기가 기회라는
말이 있듯이 지금이 어떻게 보면 되게
좋은 매물을 사기에 좋은 시기라고
저는 생각을 합니다 근데 아무래도
시기적으로도 안 좋고 지금 여러 가지
변수가 많 때문에 되게 신중하게
접근해야 될 부분이 있긴 하지만 지금
뭔가 철저하게 좀 계획하고 관심을
갖고 도전을 한다라고 하면은 좋은
매물을 살 수 있는 최적의 기회라고
저는 생각하기 때문에이 부분을
기억하셨다가 부동산 경매로 좀 기회를
찾으셨으면 좋겠습니다 오늘 영상
여기까지 하고요 빌딩은 역시
[음악]
빌사남 I